this isn't how many americans thought
they'd be spending their christmas week
this queue in new york was just to get
on the waiting list for a covid test
the queues have grown as omicron has
surged in the u.s the variant accounting
for almost three quarters of all
infections recorded last week
those looking for home testing kits are
also likely to draw a blank as millions
of americans weigh up whether it's safe
to travel to see family in the holidays
from joe biden then the promise of more
testing and more resources came with a
warning the tone uncompromising the
message far from festive
get vaccinated now it's free
it's convenient
i promise you it saves lives
and i honestly god believe it's your
patriotic duty
i know vaccination requirements are
unpopular
for many
i'm not even popular for those who are
anxious to get them
my administration has put them in place
not to control your life but to save
your life
because it is full vaccination with a
booster shot that his administration
says is the best chance of making it
through but still some 40 million
americans are yet to have their first
shot
there is no new lockdown but there is
the feeling of going back in time
theaters on broadway are closed the
attractions that remain open do so with
reduced capacity
as with everywhere in the world there is
uncertainty here about what omicron will
ultimately mean how long we'll remain in
its grip how much we're in for an
unhappy new year greg milam sky news los
angeles